because they think is autumn I don't
think anyone should do what I don't
anyone should do something I hate doing
no one should do that and financial
freedom doesn't mean don't work anymore
it means you have the choice you have
the choice to do what you enjoy doing so
you can you can live a life of freedom
and actually being a job I mean the job
in a way because I'm still come to the
office like everyone comes to the office
but it's from choice and I think that's
the same for everyone everyone has a
choice to be here or not you have a
choice to be sat on this chair maybe
this podcast you doing what you enjoy
doing so I think when you really believe
that when you've got a team of people on
a mission they've got the same values
the same heart and all doing different
roles but they actually enjoy their own
yeah then that's great because some
people love doing my are net you've got
one the employee of the month
just-just-just today he loves doing
finance he loves it now you probably
wouldn't enjoy it so much I don't know
you know so I fill my diary of stuff
that I love but I would also want the
same for everyone in the business I tell
the same to you guys I'm like do what
you like what would that ask you at the
last at the last meeting that we had in
the room and I want to know what you all
love doing because it's also as long as
you're doing stuff that's also
productive that if I said I love video
games and eating then then that's then
I'm not serving anybody so how can i how
can I be of best value
and be be of use in the best way but
also be doing something that I really
enjoy doing
I think dr. John Demartini says
something yeah he said what does he say
he says how can I do what I love and get
paid handsomely to do it if you love
what you do then you'll never work a day
in your life so is that kind of advice
you would give to people when they're
looking for what to do just what would
you do if you weren't gonna be paid yeah
but he's also got a memo yeah so you
know you've got it you've got about to
make it yeah well what what do you enjoy
doing what are you good at what you're
passionate about and then you're not
having to look at the clock and thing
another when I was at school I just
watched the people day I couldn't wait
to leave and you know I just think that
sucks is that why you're such a big
advocate for leaving school if you feel
like you're being pulled somewhere else
yeah because people go to school just
because they want to please their
parents
and they go to university just because
it's all smokes and mirrors and on the
basis that they'll get a job when they
leave University a job doing something
they don't want to do like it's just a
complete hoax what why would you go to
university to study something to get a
job doing something that you don't
actually want to do to make a living why
don't just figure out how to make a
living do something now some people I
believe that some people just will not
be successful in life
and it's not because they can't it's
just because they won't they're there
that much fear they have that they're
that they're skeptical there that
unprepared to take action no matter what
I can do is a trainer no matter what
advice I can give them they're just
never gonna be successful it's never
gonna happen for them and I believe that
I can spend three minutes with pretty
much any person on the planet and I'll
be able to tell them wherever they're
gonna be successful in business or
property or not I you just tell I can
meet someone and within a few minutes
chat with them I just I just know if
they're gonna be successful or not and
if they're not they can be broke as
anything but I can tell okay you're
broke right now but yes you you're gonna
be successful because I can tell from
their mind I can tell from the way their
language they use the way this big boy
they think anyone can make themself
famous but if you haven't got any
content or charisma or persistence to be
consistent then you probably is probably
not not gonna happen but but yeah anyone
[Music]